[Music]
[Applause]
uh Joey VTO our good buddy with the
Cincinnati Red six-time Allstar won an
MVP won a gold glove and he's here to
announce his retirement from Major
League Baseball and it's very nice that
you very very thoughtful that you picked
this show to announce your retirement
Bittersweet Bittersweet Forest but I'll
let you make the announcement hey how
about a round of applause Jo
Joey a her career unbelievable unbeliev
we're going to miss you we're gonna miss
you am I am I am I on
yeah oh man I was worried uh I don't
have anything to talk about today and uh
that start that's quite the intro
so I uh I'd like to announce my
retirement from this particular show um
once again a round of applause for Joey
B hell of a run yeah I didn't say what
he's retiring from but he's retiring
from this show and I I hear that you're
on your way to retirement years okay who
retires first me or you for sure me okay
what is your status right
now
unemployed unemployed and um no I I'm
I'm I they have a um an option for 2024
and I don't know what's next so uh as
far as being retired I'm not retired
quite yet okay but if you had your
DRS if I had my brothers You're come
you're going back to the redge yeah yeah
of of course I want to I want to play
again one more at least one more year
yeah okay last yeah the last couple
years were crummy I didn't uh I wasn't
healthy for two years so I'd like to
play well it's not the taste I want to I
want to leave in in my mouth but if the
Reds decide that they are not going to
exercise that
option then uh then I'll have a new
experience Dan it is good to see you it
is good to see you it's been a long time
yeah it's really good to see you no I if
um if if if not then I'll have a new
experience I'll be a free agent for the
first time in my professional baseball
career so I don't know how excited I am
about that yeah I wonder about that that
like show Otani going into free agency
no obviously it's different than you but
just that experience of you know you're
kind of like going on dates you know
like blind date or something hey come on
to Boston and say hello to the red sock
or things like that can you imagine what
his life is going to be like here coming
up um well you brought a Boston I've
actually flown to Boston for actual
dates before so that is not new
territory for me
I I remember uh flying having a day off
flying intentionally into Boston going
on a date with this woman and actually
flying back so all of that is is is is
familiar territory for me so the advice
I give Shi if he's going to fly to
Boston and go on a date I'd say you know
make sure you have a return ticket for
that night because it may not be a good
match so it worked out fine for me as
far as sh uh free agency I have no idea
because getting you know going through
that Tommy John surgery May interrupt
the momentum of what some teams were
anticipating in terms of the pitcher
hitting hitter Comber for combo for
2024 but he seems as confident as ever
and offensively he was as good as anyone
in the game this year so you know I
don't think I don't think there's going
to be much of an interruption in terms
of interest from from the teams that
really really wanted him I mean pause
for a year return to pitching in 2025
and and uh everyone gets the best of
yeah I just wonder if it it was going to
be 600 or maybe 500 and now it's $450
million with incentives uh if he pitches
again or when he pitches again yeah but
why why why is it such a massive
hit well he's not going to be pitching
we don't know if he's going to be don't
you want to pay him in accordance to
he's going to be the two-way player uh
just the marketing of that um not just a
hitter maybe a
pitcher well I I think there would have
been uncertainty going into any contract
especially if there would have been you
know that 8 to 12 year length I think
anybody would have built in that
uncertainty that you get the guarant
guarantee that he won't be pitching in
year one dings him I suppose a little
bit but I don't know if it dings the the
full package as much as people would
think and he's in a position where I
think he feels like he's in in really
power powerful position he had such a
good offensive year people have a really
strong idea of of what it feels like
coming back from Tommy John surgery so I
think he feels like okay this is not
ideal for my new team or if he goes back
to Anaheim for Anaheim but I think he
views himself as like a pitcher hitter
long term talking to Joey vad he's not
retiring from the Reds just the show
joining us on the program the uh playoff
format first round three games M how did
the how do you think the players if the
players could vote on three game best of
three or a oneand
done what do you think they would choose
I think they PR we prefer three games
because we're used to a three- game
series and the one game it just it it
just all happens so quickly we're used
to entering a city preparing practicing
playing uh going through the weekend and
then and then um or or the three game
series and then heading back to the are
are heading off to New City so you know
I don't think we want to do a one game
series but I can't speak for all all
players what um you look at the these
teams and face these teams but give me a
scouting report on the
Dodgers I don't know I haven't I haven't
really paid attention to it I thought we
were going to talk about like Taylor
Swift you know I'm single Travis Kelce
gets tra Taylor Swift you know I The
Experience from me as a 40-year-old a
single 40-year-old watching Travis
Kelce date Taylor Swift and know that if
he has a good game he's going to get a
Rolls-Royce at the end of the night know
that if he has a good game he's going to
get a brand new Rolex at the end of the
night know that no matter what there's
going to be you know he's going to be
flying private jets all over the place
and living this you know Posh Taylor
Swift like life you should ask my
opinion on that one because I've got a
take on that one okay what is your take
on Taylor Swift and Travis Kelce I I'd
like to be the backup
boyfriend I'd like to be the backup
boyfriend to Travis Kelce so if that's
available I'll take you wait oh wait not
Travis Kel's boyfriend but the backup to
Travis Kelce as the boyfriend for Taylor
swim yes I I'd like to be the second
line okay yep have you made any um
inroads to Taylor Swift before
overtures is that I'm kind of doing it
right now am I not oh you're shooting
your shot right now I'm not even
shooting the a shot I'm shooting the B
shot the backup shot I would love to be
the
backup okay okay yeah Dam well you're
gonna have to play again so you can
invite her to come to the
game because she's not going to go oh
let me look at your stat like she
doesn't care about that she wants to be
seen so you have to go play one more
year maybe play in a you know different
Market he's in Kansas City though it's a
smaller Market
she'll get bored she'll get bored by
that well I can promise you I will bore
her
and have you dated somebody famous
before no never okay you don't want to
go into that
world I don't know I can only imagine
what it's like no you don't want that
you don't no then you can't go to
Starbucks and get you can't go you know
just have a normal day you can't wear
that shirt it's a nice shirt no it's not
no it's not no okay see you can't you
can't do that what you wear what you
know I mean everything you're going to
be scrutinized how are you when you get
criticized when you're you know playing
baseball imagine that times a million
social media is coming after you I'd cry
a lot H well she might like
that yeah yeah yeah when's the last time
you
cried
uh the other day I thought oh this might
be my last day last game okay so the the
day before the last game in Cincinnati I
thought oh this might be my last game
playing in Cincinnati and so I was
sitting on my couch at home the night
before playing a bunch of like I played
Landslide by Fleetwood Mack probably
about 15 times in a row and that part
where it says you know I've been afraid
of changing because I live my life I
built my life around you right I played
that like 15 times and I was balling
thinking about you know the end of my
tenure the end of my relationship with
the Cincinnati Reds and so you know with
the fan base with the experience so yeah
that was the last time I cried and I
cried hard pretty hard see this is what
we send to Taylor
Swift this right here this is this is a
home run right here and a picture of the
empty slot in my garage I could
definitely I would love to have that her
to have that info so maybe she decides
to buy me a new new car or something
yeah you don't you don't need anything
like that you need love you don't need
material things you're better than that
aren't you no no I need material things
I tried love before a new
car why hasn't love worked for
you well d
H is it you it's me it's me would
you it's okay right yeah can I help you
with anything here I mean while we're
putting out we're putting out the vibe
right now that's 20 yeah yes we are okay
just want to make sure uh do you even
care who wins the world I mean I could
ask you a baseball question but I don't
do you care who wins the World Series
well if you asked me before the play
playoffs I would have said us I would
have said the Reds but um
now uh no I it I just want I want the
fans to be entertained this year and
I'll go on my little like uh Major
League Baseball representative stick
here you know we had a huge uptick in
attendance general interest was better
game was faster more appeal a lot of
satisfaction so you know I want our
sport to be appealing you know there's
been at times over the last 20 years or
so uh downtick in terms of Interest
especially for the playoffs this should
be our goal time so hopefully hopefully
we get to give the fans exactly what
they're looking for would you like to be
commissioner
no no I don't think so at all no Rob's
doing I think Rob's doing a good job
okay like a de a decade from
now a decade from
now no I think when I'm done playing and
I've already you know the little trick
about being semi-retired Dan is I I I
applied to school last spring and I go
to I take online schooling in the fall
and then I just applied to Chef's School
in January so if there's no interest in
the league I've already got I've already
got a new career so you know we'll see
we'll see what's next for me but if Pro
I probably won't be the next
Commissioner of Major League Baseball oh
man the fact that you emote you cry
listening to Stevie Nicks that you're
going to learn how to
cook that is boyfriend material that's
appealing that is appealing that that
that is that is that is a commodity that
most are searching for so you know we'll
see we'll see what kind of response we
get from this interview I I would say if
you get lonely when you get lonely and
you want somebody to talk to then when
I'm not lonely it's more like when I'm
not alone yeah go ahead like I you know
you can just call in if I can help you
in any way being more than happy if you
just got to get things off your mind if
you want to listen to Landslide and we
listen to it together I'd be more than
happy to do that you know we could play
it 15 consecutive times on this show if
you want to and I'd be more than happy
to sit there with you would you cry yeah
maybe but I'm an actor so when the when
the Reds when the Reds kick you to the
curb and then you're all by
yourself
yeah all together now just let it sink
in here
Stevie
changeing cuz I've build my life around
[Music]
you Reds are going to kick me to the
curb I'll be playing in
Minnesota hey there's no shame in
playing Minnesota they're still in the
playoffs oh I know that I know that they
could use an extra stick well I'd be the
backup stick well that's what you are to
Taylor wait
no I didn't say that I didn't say that
batting
cleanup Travis I'll take it from here
okay uh so good luck and we're here for
you apprciate yeah we're here for you
goodbye all right yes okay yes right
could you give me a little Stevie next
landslide to send Joey vad into deep
dark
depression once again he's not retiring
from baseball he's retiring from this
show and frankly I can't blame him as he
turns his head to the side so the camera
can't see the tears coming down his
cheek we say goodbye to Joey vad maybe
forever yeah there he goes
wow take a break and come back after
this try to gather
ourselves